hi I'm Brian ear
welcome to paradise ranch pet resort my
wife Kristen Ghadir is the originator of
the cage free dog boarding concept and
tomorrow's our anniversary so happy
Anniversary sweetheart
hi I'm Cora and this is Alice my name is
Beecher Pope and this is my dog Zuzu hi
my name is Danny and this is my puppy
guy what you're gonna do is you're gonna
play in five playgrounds maybe you get
your nails done get your teeth brush
you're gonna get timing your life with a
spot little guy and I hope you enjoy cuz
you deserve it you're a great little
puppy thanks buddy
so our philosophy is that when owners go
on vacation that their dogs deserve to
be on vacation too
they don't want to be locked up they
want to play with other dogs and be in
vacation
I think dark paradise is being in a
balanced pack with other dogs you can
actually see them walking around with
smiles on their faces
you
for me he's the perfect dog as soon as I
met him it was like one of her sight you
know just clicked as soon as I found him
it doesn't feel like a dog that you have
it feels like you have another like
brother or sister if I'm having a rough
day she knows it and she's there for me
with a good snuggle
I hope that Ellis enjoyed the day at the
spa I think that going and getting a
good scrub and soak in a little pot a
cure will definitely make her feel good
about herself she's a pretty lady the
thing that I love about dogs is that
dogs will love their owner their alpha
dog unconditionally dogs are the most
loving loyal people on the planet
Ellis hi did you have a good day you
must be exhausted oh my god
your nails look better than mine do